everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
do some CSS so not sass or CSS and J s
or anything like that just regular CSS
this should be a great stream for
beginners because usually if you want to
get into web development you start out
with HTML and CSS so I hope that we have
no technical issues with the stream I
could see my mic is working today and so
far I've not dropped any frames so this
might be the first successful stream
from my my home office which is actually
just a corner of my laundry room in my
basement right now but don't I'm not
gonna do a lengthy introduction I think
you know we'll just get started
I do want to show off my my t-shirt so
this is the November t-shirt from the
conference the 2017 November conference
so I was pretty cool bad cool stuff
there I know I you've seen I think I've
worn other stuff before or put it on
Instagram or something there's a t-shirt
a hoodie at November hat I got socks
from that conference the socks were from
Heroku but anyway just wanted to show
that off before we get started if you're
new to the stream let me just give you a
very quick rundown of how things go this
stream is not exactly a tutorial instead
this is my day to day work as a
front-end developer for a small
university so whatever I need to work on
that day I just pick whatever I think
will be the most interesting thing and
then I stream it for about an hour so
but I take breaks to answer questions
and I try to narrate what I'm doing
so that you know hopefully it's
beneficial to you all that watch and
then you can give me you know your your
feedback and your help and ideas as I go
along so it ends up being very
collaborative a time these with a
Pomodoro timer which means for 25
minutes
I mostly code and don't really look too
much at the live chat then I take a
little break and I answer questions to
live chat then I go back and do another
25-minute session and then after that I
go back and in the final part of the
stream is just all question and answer
and sometimes it takes a long time
sometimes it doesn't it entirely depends
on you and and your questions this is
definitely beginner friendly feel free
to ask any questions don't worry about
you know if you think your question is
is a silly question don't worry about it
you know we're all trying to learn here
and get better and we're always trying
to be very helpful if somebody is being
not very nice in the chat then I will
talk to them about that I I've only had
to ban somebody once so you know we've
been doing these streams for almost a
year now
and so we have a pretty good track
record of having you know kind of a
positive experience here so having said
that let's get started so I'm going to
start my Pomodoro clock and I'm gonna
start out by just showing you what's
what we're gonna work on so I want to go
to the major j/s page if you all want to
follow along where you know at home you
can go to the github repository that's
linked in the description to this video
and check out this major j/s component
that's in the pages folder that's where
we're gonna spend most of our time well
I take that back
we're probably gonna create a CSS file
and that's what we're gonna spend most
sort of time so it's probably not a bad
idea to see if we already have one so
the under static styles no we don't so
we we actually don't have a CSS file for
this component so that's kind of nice
we'll start from a blank one and now I'm
gonna let you see what we need the style
it's it's a little bit tricky so we have
a lot of freedom with what we're gonna
turn this into whoops let me switch the
same so y'all can see oh there we go
okay
all right so this is what we currently
have this is the the current site that
we're redoing so there's this thing here
where user can click and get you know
potentially what their schedule could be
if they decided to come to the
University and take B it'd be a classics
major right so I got some feedback from
some current students and they said that
they really like this and this helped
them a lot when they were deciding so I
do want to make this nicer this is what
it looks like currently so we brought
over all the markup and none of the
styles so it's just a list so our goal
today is to take this list and turn it
into something that basically does this
it does not have to look like this at
all
we can completely change how this looks
but it just needs to in a reasonable way
that would be nice for you
user it needs to be able to display the
classes that would be taken during you
know during their different years and
semesters and we have to work with the
existing markup so potentially I could
change the markup but there's a lot and
we're running out of time but before you
know launch time so I'm thinking so this
probably needs to be launched sometime
in maybe this month let me think
hold on a second let me when's the first
day of summer is it June
yeah it's June right so let's let's
figure the launch date is gonna be
sometime in early June
kind of at the latest so anyway I would
like to just work with the markup as is
at a later date we can go back and if we
want to change markup and organize the
data in a better way that's fine but
otherwise have just brought this over as
is and that's what we're gonna work with
all right Michael says June 21st okay I
thought it was June I just realized I
haven't looked at all at the chat since
we started so I am gonna go back and
read this I just want to scan quickly to
make sure there's nothing wrong with my
stream that you are telling me about
okay all right looks like everything's
good with the stream so first thing
we're gonna do is just check out what we
have in dev tools so it's inspected and
I know on some streams I have a tool
running called an grok that allows you
to inspect things on your own computer I
don't have an grukk running right now
for two reasons one I don't even have it
installed or set up on this computer but
also I don't think this computer could
handle running and rock and doing a live
stream at the same time I would like to
test it out at some point it would have
been good for this type of stream but
now it's kind of too late to try it out
anyway I didn't really think about it
until we already started all right so
I'm gonna make this a bit bigger so
right now what I'm just looking for is
like what markup are we are we dealing
with here what does this look like so
let's see it looks like alright so we
have an h2 at the top it's just good oh
and then okay so these are also aged
twos not really happy about that I mean
this is obviously the header for the
whole thing so I would have liked it if
these were maybe a ch3 s or something
but that's what we have and then these
are in left title tags so what we've
noticed previously that when we're
bringing over data from this older
content management system called Ektron
we have a lot of custom elements so this
is one of those a left title alright we
have break tags we have left interesting
we have tags they're just left tags and
then Wow even all the courses
our h2s with a class of title and then a
link we have an a link tag that has
nothing in it it looks like we have
display:none set on a link which I mean
that that obviously makes sense right
okay so I'm assuming we're gonna have
some right tags here so let's check it
out okay right title and we have some
right tags okay this is not it's not
terrible see okay and then this is a
link and I already set up this route so
this link actually works so that's what
I was doing earlier today I was just
going through cleaning up data setting
up routes which is what I've been doing
pretty much every day the last couple of
weeks there's a lot to go through all
right and then each one of these is in a
tab ok all right I think this markup is
something we can work with this doesn't
look it doesn't look it could have been
a lot worse right based on what we were
seeing before it could have been worse
so I think this will work we should be
able to do what we need to do so right
off the bat then I'm gonna tell you what
I'm thinking about doing and then you
all can give me your feedback and and
see if if you have any you know any
input maybe I'm missing something so I
mean obviously I'm not I'm gonna use
these left tags and left title for
that's where I'm gonna attach the
positioning to so in our CR CSS we're
gonna target these and position them to
the left or to the right since there's
no like containers I'm thinking this is
going to be tough
yeah there's no containers around all
this which is gonna make it a little bit
tough maybe we'll just do like old
fashioned floats and see if that works
for our right in our left I mean
normally I would go with something else
but that's gonna be maybe my first try
and then it looks like these BR tags are
just way too much space so we may end up
just setting these to like display:none
or something like that let's take it
okay yeah if we set display:none on
those that's that's a lot nicer so just
like that that automatically looks more
reasonable we're also gonna have to
change some of the styles on like these
titles for semesters and years so right
now there's no visual hierarchy in terms
of font size font weight color or
indentation so all that's gonna have to
change and then the the link styling
will change this is just default link
styling so we'll switch that up but
other than that it's not it's not really
terrible yeah I think that's too bad
we'll get that all figured out and then
we'll see what it looks like with just
having first year first semester and
then side-by-side and then doing the
same thing here and then we'll see like
do we want to go back to some sort of
tabbed version is it okay to just have
them all right there I'm not really sure
I want to see it first
all right so let me look at the live
chat since I've been asking a few
questions here and see see what you all
think
all right I see I see a lot of questions
in the chat right now so I will get to
the questions so in about about 15
minutes I'll get to the questions so
please be patient
let's see
how mummy says so will not modify the
HTML at all if potentially we can modify
the HTML but if we do it it's gonna be
using javascript in the react component
because I have a lot of pages that have
markup just like this so I don't want to
have to manually go in and modify it oh
and it hard should Ted just explain that
so sorry I didn't see that okay well it
looks like we're good to starting on
this so first thing I want to do is is
try to get this positioning working so
let's go you know what let's just try to
do a little bit right here in dev tools
if you're very new to using you know dev
tools you know if you just right-click
on anything in the page and then go down
to inspect dev tools will come up if you
never used it before it'll come up and
it'll be white instead of a black
background you can just go into the
settings up here and you can change that
to a dark background if you want all
right so all the changes we're going to
do here you're just gonna be temporary
they're only work in our browser so you
don't have to worry about actually
changing you're messing up the code and
you can do this for any website that you
go on to just kind of mess with it and
see how it works so we're gonna take our
left tags and let's see actually let me
go with the right ones first let's see
no I don't do it the left so let's try a
float:left see how weird it looks all
right so what did we just we just took
nope that's not gonna work you know I
didn't even think about that okay
so let's leave that alone for now let's
take our right ones and let's see what
we can do well I should sisters 101
people watching which is more I well I
haven't even looked at the analytics at
all wow so we're at 85 right now based
on my analytics but that's still a lot
of people so for ever new people welcome
thanks for thanks for watching feel free
to put any questions you have in the
chat and I'll answer them after a little
while alright so let's go with our write
tags and let's see what we can do so we
can do so I'm obviously the floats not
gonna work right so if we do float right
we're gonna get some weirdness again so
float is out for what we're doing right
now but we could maybe do let's mess
with the position whoops and that did
not position:absolute no this is not
this is going to be trickier than I
thought so the lack of a container is
really messing this up
alright one thing we can do is see what
they used here in the old site assuming
that they have the the same elements on
the page all right so this ended up
getting interpreted as ul unordered list
Wow okay so it looks like the old
content management system took those
those custom tags and converted them to
normal HTML tags and ended up wrapping
these so think of think of these as like
components in react so now actually it
doesn't make any sense either I'm not
exactly sure how that that worked out
because you know there's really not any
type of container
interesting okay let's start with
something easier while we think about
how we can do how we can do this let's
just get the headings fixed in terms of
the size font weight in color I have
some ideas for how to handle the
positioning but it's gonna involve from
JavaScript so I'd rather stick to CSS
for now since that's what I
I made the title of this video so I
imagine there's a lot of people here for
the CSS so let's do some CSS then and
sample programs this h2 is let's check
we don't want it to be too much larger
than this so let's look up what we have
on this h1 okay so we don't have
anything special it's just default so
probably not not really a bad idea to
just keep it as is for now since it's
it's the appropriate size and weight in
relation to this but these h2s
that's why have an extra title here
it's really interesting okay why these
do not stand out at all
all right we're gonna do some weird CSS
here for a second so I'm gonna write
this let's set up our CSS our file so we
have our Styles right now are we pulling
in any styles okay we're actually
pulling in the styles from News dot CSS
so you may want to pull those styles
over let's make a new file first and
we'll call this major dot CSS to match
our component of major dot CSS let's
check out our news CSS and you know what
let me make some more space here let's
move this over cuz we're not really
using it right now and we'll move our
our terminal stuff down and then I'm
gonna make this a bit bigger so it'll be
easier for you all to see okay hopefully
that is easier to see so what I'm gonna
do is take everything that's currently
in news dot CSS and I'm gonna move it
over to major dot CSS because I'm not
sure what in this file is really making
a difference in our major J s component
so I'm gonna save that let's go over to
our component of major dot J s sorry
that for the lag it's just you know
trying to run the live stream and
everything else makes it a little slow
so we're right now we're bringing in if
you don't know what's going on in this
particular component don't worry about
it if you're not familiar with react you
know it's it's totally cool if you don't
understand but we're basically just
importing styles alright with a link tag
so that should be you know from
- you sure I'm just you know writing
normal HTML so we're gonna pull in this
major dot CSS file so now anything that
we change here will be reflected let's
see so let's go through this just a bit
I'm gonna say okay so right now anything
that is displaying his roots gets
display:none and we did have something
that was roots or was it I thought we
had something
yeah so it's root Ted all right
we have probably some of these will be
we won't necessarily need to keep them
but we'll sort that out later on right
now let's add some more styles to the
bottom so what I want to target our h2s
with the class of title so the h2s dot
title and then I want to say not want to
do this [ __ ] first
I might have to look up the syntax so
what I want to select is all the h2s
that have the class of title except not
oh you know what I was mistaken this h2
is just stacked so this one doesn't have
the class of title so we're gonna we're
good then okay that makes this a lot
easier so normally I'm not I don't like
manipulating h2s we still want this
title so in CSS what we're doing is
selecting an h2 and then we do dot title
this right after that that means any h2s
with the class of title if I had a space
here
this would mean any element with the
class of title that exists inside of an
h2 so you could see that little tooltip
is displaying what it would be but now
if we backspace it you can see we're
looking for h2s with the class of title
and only h2s okay so I know for most of
you that's probably you know you're
probably familiar with that but I do
want to try to explain as much as I can
you know for anybody that's just just
curious about web development just
starting out so right now we're we're
targeting these year titles so this
first year you know second second year
so we want to make this
so let's just test it out here font size
18 pixels okay so we're gonna go up from
there and let's see let's say 24 pixels
I really don't want to go any more than
24 pixels on this one and we could do
font weight and let's see 500 okay 500
looks good that definitely makes it
thinner and then can we do color let's
make our color be RGB a and we're gonna
use 0 0 0 0.87 sunny commas done' zero
okay so I wasn't sure if that was the
color or not but that's what color I
want okay so let's go with that for now
and also we need to remember to make
those those BR tags work so major route
239 BR all right so we're definitely
gonna have to override this style where
is it getting that from that's weird
okay so we're copy and pasting that in
here that's just
I want to fix indentation on that and
then let's go with BR display I hate to
use important but let's just do it just
for time I don't really want to go
through this and try to figure out what
exactly is going on with this just to
see what it looks like we're gonna go
with important in there so let's do a
refresh make sure it's working all right
cool so now we have we have that and my
timer went off so let me take a short
break and answer as many questions as I
can
there's a lot of questions here so if I
don't get to yours this time I'll get to
it after the second Pomodoro session
I'll spend that the entire end of the
stream just answering questions see so
I'm not gonna read out all the comments
just because there's so much in here I
do want to get to the questions though
although I'll probably read out comments
that are other that may be funny or
flattering to me personally so for
instance Klaus says I look way better
with the stubble instead of the beard
thanks my wife agrees world's asked if
I'm in the basement I am I'm coding from
a corner of my basement
Nilesh asked when I'll continue the
react testing video maybe later this
week I was doing I was reading a lot of
documentation on testing and I still
could not figure out what I have to do
for the the click
I I don't uh I have to talk about this
for like 20 minutes or not at all so I
will do another stream about it when I
figure it out
Remi asks how many monitors I have right
now I have a MacBook Pro so there's a
screen with that and then two external
monitors hooked up and that's my set up
at my office as well except it's an iMac
and then two external monitors the most
I've ever uses for monitors those are
really cool set up I'd like to go back
to that eventually
innocence I look younger without the
beard yeah I definitely everybody keeps
saying that that I look younger and you
probably can't see it on the live stream
but I have gray hair in my beard so I
definitely look younger because I don't
I don't yet have any gray hair like on
the top of my head so yeah definitely
younger so Lee says shout out from South
Africa thanks for watching thanks for
the shoutout
John says it is usually a good idea to
draw out a plan what divs hold what
headings in some sense of functional
ui/ux
yeah for sure normally I'm like right
now we're kind of stuck with this markup
so normally I wouldn't start like this
but many of you if you're actually going
to work will probably find yourself in a
situation where you don't have control
over the mark-up but you need to style
it as best you can and what we're doing
now is kind of a good example of how you
handle that
how many says pure CSS no bootstrap yep
no no bootstrap or nothing
yeah we sew on the components themselves
we have styles for material you eye
but we're when we're doing this in terms
of like styling the markup that's been
imported from the other CMS it's it's
pretty much all from scratch
how many asked what material UI is it's
a
a UI framework for react that uses
material design principles
the lone wolf says can anyone explain
what BR and link does the BR tags are
HTML tags that are supposed to include a
line break and potentially like some
space in between lines but really it's
better to use CSS for that like margins
padding and things like that
so I very rarely use a break tag you
know now it correct me if I'm wrong but
those were kind of a really an older
thing that you just you don't really do
that much anymore and then the link tag
I don't know what they're doing with the
link tag in here in terms of what got
imported from the old CMS but link tags
are supposed to be to pull in CSS files
sath fixes what is the left tag do it
really doesn't do anything right now
until we assign it some sort of styles
it was a custom tag that did have some
meaning in the old content management
system but doesn't currently in a new
system Javier says is this a semantic
HTML horrible on purpose I don't know
what the designers of that old CMS we're
thinking if they wanted it to be like
that on purpose or not I don't think
I'll ever get a chance to ask them so we
may never know all right so my timer
went off I'm gonna go back and start
another appointment or a session and
then I'm gonna come back to the chat and
keep going from where I left off which
is I don't think I have a pen or
anything here all right so the time
stamp for me for where I left off is
2:45 p.m. in the chat so let's try to
remember 2:45 p.m. I bet I can just
write it here yeah
let's just alright so in my terminal are
right 2:45 so remember that that's there
and then I'll remember where to go okay
so we've got our h2s with the class of
title style and we've gotten rid of
those those break tags why I shouldn't
say we got rid of them they're still
there we're just not displaying them
okay so now here's what we have we
definitely need to style these and these
right we look for one with a hierarchy
here it's not it's not looking good so
far so our left title and right title
are going to get the same styles in
terms of font and color so let's test
out what we think will look good so
we'll go with a font size of let's say
20 all right 20 pixels a little bit
bigger and do we want a different font
weights let's see what we want so the
last thing was what 500 let's try a 400
font weight which is gonna be pretty
light okay not bad and then let's take
that color we want that same color of
our G RGB a so this RGB a that I'm
putting in here if we just did the zero
zero zero that would give us pure black
but instead we're doing this 0.87 all
right and that that last one is like the
the opacity so what we're doing
is essentially making a grayish color
but we're not putting a grey hex value
in text is actually more readable if you
do solid black and you make it a little
bit transparent to get your gray if you
do a gray hex value it's less readable
so I'm not gonna do it right now I'd
like to demonstrate but you know try it
out on your own and try them
side-by-side you you'll be amazed at at
the difference
okay so that's not bad it still looks
weird because we haven't styled these
yet but you know I think we're on the
right track so let's copy this and we'll
go over to our file here and let's do
left what was that left title yeah left
title and we're gonna do right title so
since we put this comma in here it's
going to add the same styles for both of
these so let's save that just to make
sure that the styles are applying across
the board there we are okay so we have
the same styles all the way down good
now let's see what we're working with
for these each one of these all right
oh goodness all right this is not too
bad so we want to target all h2s that
have a class of title that live within a
left tag or a right tag so we can we can
definitely do that so let's let's do
this over here it's gonna be a little
tricky to do it in dev tools not not
impossible but let's just do it over
here so let's do a left tag and let's
say h2
and then let's do a write tag and then
we'll say h2 title so this will target
what we wanted to target we could hover
over that so any h2s with a class of
title that are within a left tag or a
right tag and that's what we're gonna go
with here and let's based on what we've
seen with the other things we've styled
we can pretty much guess without even
looking what's gonna work so let's do a
font size of 18 pixels and we'll do a
font weight and we're gonna keep it at
that 400 pixels if you start to go below
400 it gets a little bit difficult to
read if you have a nice screen it's okay
and it actually looks really good
but for users that have older screens
it's it's very hard to read so although
aesthetically I really like how it looks
I mean from just out of respect for a
lot of the users that may not have you
know high definition screens I'm not I'm
gonna very rarely go below 400 unless
we're talking about large font sizes and
so finally we're gonna make the color
let's just copy and paste so we don't
have to type that out again but I want
to try it with a lighter gray color
because we need a thing we need some
differentiation here because we have a
lot of levels going on so let's try a 54
usually the values I end up using or
either 87 or 54 never pure black and
this will give us a lighter gray color
that'll still be readable so well I may
refresh I do have like automatic refresh
setup here but since the there's a bit
of lag here it's kind of running a
little slow from the live stream I just
keep doing this you know
annually okay so let me zoom in here
it's easy to see so right now we do have
this font wait looks a little big left
h2 title that's interesting why is this
did I mess it up
oops I put pixels in the font wait I'm
sure some of you already caught that and
put it in the hand the live chat so
sorry if I didn't glanced over there but
yeah that's can't put pixels in the font
wait it's just a regular you know number
okay that that looks nicer so this what
we have right now not too bad
well we forgot to style this I'm not
that worried about style at night so I'm
gonna leave that alone for now and let's
see so we'll come to the page I just
kind of wanted to like zoom out and just
see the big picture here so we come to
the page we see the mission Ames
okay and now we go down sample program
classics first year first semester
second semesters okay it's a it's a bit
much it is a bit much you know what I
wonder
let's shrink this down and see what it
would look like on a small screen like
on a phone it's it's not too bad I think
there needs to be some some work with
the padding and the margins here so we
need you know better spacing so it
doesn't all run together and I think we
don't need links for each one of these
so for this oho so if
this one it has it here because this
whole thing changes when you click it so
that's why it keeps repeating that link
so we don't need to do that I do want to
see what what happens when this goes
small okay interesting
all right so it doesn't display them all
but it still has this kind of stacked
look within each one okay
all right not it's not terrible I don't
think we're gonna get into doing
anything like this right now but I'm
gonna keep that open is kind of a
possibility here okay all right so let's
go back to what we have here and
all right let's see where this whoops
with this inspect that and okay do you
all so this is within a view-all tag and
[Music]
classics classes text that's really
weird I don't want it to say that um
alright why it says that okay so let's
take these view all tags and
mmm which one are we going to I wonder
if we could all right let me let me just
go over what I'm kind of thinking now so
I'm thinking we definitely don't need
the same link four times on the page we
really just need it one time oh excuse
me we need to link one time and my
thought was okay well let me hide all of
them except for one but I also had a
thought that you know the the URL for
this is going to be pretty predictable
it's just going to be classics and
classes so potentially we could just put
into our into our component another
element there in our component to
display it and it can just add in our
our slug right for that particular page
into here and just build the URL like
that the benefit of doing it that way is
that we can use link prefetching so
right now this is built-in so if I click
this we're gonna get a page or flesh so
let's let's see see we get a page
refresh which obviously takes longer so
we don't really want that yeah so let's
do it let's do it like that so first
things first let's take view all and
we're gonna say let's just put it right
here with this Br
all right so if you all is gonna be
display:none and then we'll just put in
and that's also gonna solve the problem
of the text here being weird like
classics classes text doesn't really say
to the user what's gonna be on that page
so I guess I'll have to refresh my auto
refresh is just not happening all right
there we go so we've gotten rid of that
and just to add this in I guess we could
add this in quickly let me see how much
time I have ten minutes okay that's
enough time we can go back to our major
J s and we could see what we're gonna
get is our ID I believe is what we're
gonna want and that would be classic all
right so let's go down here our query is
bringing in all this data so after that
yeah we can put our other element after
that so let's just add a link tag and
make sure we've imported our link tag we
have not and we can just copy and paste
it from an existing component so I know
we have your item J s is doing this so
we're going to import link from next
link so this part here is getting a
little bit more advanced
we're using react so if you're not
familiar with this don't worry about it
this is definitely not CSS stuff but I'm
just gonna copy and paste a few things
just to save time and then we're gonna
get back to our CSS link
okay and link there we go so alright
this will get Auto formatted I know it
looks weird now but we don't need a key
for this whoops and we can put yeah
let's do so this is going to be template
literal so template literal is when you
want to put in a string but you want to
also have some JavaScript in there as
well it makes it a lot easier than
having to do a normal string and then
concatenate that together with plus
signs with some some JavaScript so what
we want to do is just put whoops let's
do this first part is gonna be our our
ID so this Rob's ID I just did we do
yeah this props ID okay so we have this
props ID and I forgot forget this so
when we want to use JavaScript and put a
dollar sign and some curly brackets and
then after the next curly bracket we
drop right back into string land and we
can just put the string which is which
is classes all right so that's what
works here and let's see let's look over
here I'm glad we have this open so we
did have some weirdness going on where
we needed we needed to add some things
and
page type academics and images so let's
let's pull this in just to see okay so
[Music]
hold phones and falling this in this
page is it really page are we doing this
I think we're doing these classes as a
major types notes
no major ID ID is gonna be this props ID
whoops
- class let's change this to template
literal syntax so we need I'm gonna
explain what I'm doing here in just a
second and hope that it works is gonna
be course descriptions all right let's
say that okay so assuming this kind of
work which I'm assuming here is that
we're adding in the URL that will be
seen in the browser but we're also
adding in this as and this is gonna send
some data to our to a router and enable
this link to act as client-side routing
so that's why we're we're kind of doing
this if you wonder why we do it like
this check out tell me what issue or
pull requests you know what if anybody's
interested in the why let me know in the
live chat and I will take the time to
look up where the you can get more info
about this in the repository otherwise
if nobody's really interested then I'm
not gonna look it up right now but let's
let's see if this even works
there we go course descriptions and
yeah not working I did the wrong thing
if he has to check the server to see if
I'm using the correct crack words here
so majors I this could be a problem all
right let's see that makes a difference
you know what I flipped them around
that's what I was worried about okay so
the as URL needs to go as the href all
right let's switch it I mess it up makes
a lot more sense now alright so this
needs to be as and this needs to be a
trip all right
okay now let me refresh make sure this
actually went through so it shouldn't so
what was happening is it was showing us
all those parameters when we hovered
over and that's not what it should show
us it should show us something that
looks like a normal URL all right so
this now is looking like a normal URL
and so I'm gonna click this and see what
happened yeah there we go all right so I
don't know if you caught that but what
happened was hopefully if you saw the
last time we tried to load this page it
took a while now it was very fast
because we never refresh the page it
routed client-side so that's what we
wanted to happen let's go back and click
it one more time just to see very fast
so it's using client-side routing it's
using prefetching caching so this is
gonna make the speed just that much
faster and because we did it like this
where we we put in variables instead of
hard-coding this this will now work for
every major page so they'll all have
this here now part of the problem we see
this is the we're gonna have this now at
the bottom of here so we'll have to
think about what we want to do with that
you know maybe we don't have these type
of things appear on a major page so
we'll have to work that out but for now
I'd it looks a lot better so this this
is just such a huge improvement over
what was there when we started remember
we had these huge font sizes and font
weights and the spacing was really weird
so this is not perfect
and it's not really how I want it to be
ideally but let's say we ran out of time
and didn't get to do anything else with
this this is still readable it makes
some kind of sense visually so that's
I'm okay with that for you know for what
it is for right now all right awesome
so my timer went off and now for the
rest of the stream I'm gonna do
questions although I probably should
commit this so that you all can see all
the code I gotta remember 2:45 is where
I left off so let's do a git status if
you're not familiar with get this will
be like a really really tiny basic
tutorial so when we use git status as
the command in our terminal it shows us
that we've modified the major Jas file
and that we've added a major dot CSS
file and that's exactly what we worked
on so that's that's what I expected to
see so that's good let's we need to add
these files to the staging area now so
we're gonna do a git add and I want to
add all the files so I'm just gonna put
a period there hit enter now if we do a
git status you can see these are green
now they're in the this they're staged
right so they're ready to be committed
and I'm gonna use this command called
Garn cm this does not come with get by
default this was in addition just to
help us make nice commit messages so
let's say we're gonna add a new feature
and we're just gonna write a very short
statement explaining what we did and
would you say add styles 4 cores 4
sample sample schedules
sample class schedules so you want it to
be short but descriptive enough that
you'll be able or someone else will be
able to go back and read it and say okay
I know what that's about
so think like one sentence it's great
there we are
and are there breaking changes no does
it affect any open issues I believe it
does let me see I don't think I have
that open I do yes let's check out the
issues here style sample program
sections so that's issue 102 so let's
say that yes it does affect an open
issue and let's say it affects issue
number 102 now it's going to run some
tests and I actually I changed one thing
in the repository and for those of you
who are contributing this should help
you out a long time ago just kind of for
demonstration purposes I had set the
end-to-end testing to not use the
headless version of Chrome browser so it
actually popped up with a browser and
you could see it going through the pages
and then that was taking longer than it
needed to so I went back and I set that
to actually use the headless version and
it cut the times about in half so if you
had a slower computer your end end test
might be timing out is a timeout after a
30 seconds I think so it should be
better now if you download the latest
changes I just committed them right
before the stream started so hopefully
that'll help with with the time no sorry
about that I just I didn't realize that
I never switched it back which I should
have because I could see it happening
every time
all right so let me go back while that's
doing its thing I'm gonna scroll back up
to was at that time Sam 2:45 and I'm
gonna answer as many questions as I can
here I should be able to I should be
able to get to all the questions
hmmm e says so will not modify the HTML
at all no not if we can help it I'm not
opposed to using Java Script though to
modify it so just like we did when we
added in that that extra link tag if we
do it in a way that could be used across
the board on all components I'm okay
with that
all right so everything passed and now
we can do a git push origin and that'll
push all our changes right up to our
master branch so if you want to check
out what we've done you can see it now
in our github repo everything is
up-to-date
all right so I'm skipping over some of
the questions because they were answered
right away by other people in the chat
so thank you for for answering so many
questions you are being really helpful
when and answering each other's
questions well it is you know we did
have a lot more people than normal today
I don't know what it was for anybody who
may be here that's not normally here
could you let me know how did you hear
about the stream and and what made you
decide to watch it today I'm just I have
no idea what's different today I mean I
haven't checked any messages maybe I got
retweeted by somebody with a lot of
followers it doesn't even look like that
though alright yeah so I'm not really
sure yeah okay so him Mme is one of the
new ones
cool thanks for watching so I just heard
one of my kids in the background all
right he's talking to to my wife all
right I missed it harsh should had said
he was gonna go to sleep so if you watch
the end of this horror thank you so much
for all your help here and in the live
chat answering questions and thank you
for staying up so late in harsh it's
timezone it's it's well after midnight
so what is it might be like yeah it's
really late it's like the middle of the
night
I need to get some better lighting see
my it's really dark in here hi
lone wolf says I'm just done through CSS
HTML bootstrap and the front-end course
is that enough for me to comprehend all
of this you could probably comprehend
all the like the CSS stuff if you're not
familiar with react it may be a little
bit more difficult to get what's going
on there but I try to do this best the
best job that I can with explaining
things along the way and you can ask you
know feel free to ask questions so I'd
say give it a shot if you find that it's
really difficult to follow along then
you know it may be maybe the stream at
this point it's not for you but I I do
try to do a mix of things that are you
know different types of things different
levels so you know some of them might be
good you know for you where you're at
right now some of them you know maybe
not
oh yeah you know what Phoenix has a good
point the the main benefit I could see
to this stream is seeing what it's like
for a front-end developer to actually
work through issues on a project have
things break problems come up and you
know try to try to just work through it
and fix it also the ability to ask
questions with so many you know really
knowledgeable developers here in the
live chat is as good as well so in the
sense of this being like a tutorial for
let's say reactor or anything it's not
really that but it can give some I I
mean I think it get some good
experiences to you know what do you do
when things don't work when you have
deadlines you know what and you can't
get everything done like what do you do
how do you handle that and I try to
explain what happens like you know if I
have a meeting and somebody wants
something changed or I disagree with the
change but we still have to do it yeah
things like that that you don't really
get in any tutorials or online courses
but you deal with you know in in the
real world and jobs so we talk about
stuff like that so I think that's really
even if you don't necessarily understand
the coding part of it you know things
like that anybody can understand
lone wolf asks where do I learn reactor
angular
there's a lot of so the react
documentation itself is really good
Udacity has a react course it's a paid
course though I went I did the react
nano degree through Udacity and I I
thought it was valuable but you don't
have to spend money there's a lot of you
know free react courses out there think
I know some of you have used some react
stuff so if you can think of any good
react courses put it in a live chat now
please what else if I used I think code
Academy has a react course so you know
between some you know YouTube videos and
some of the documentation and the free
courses out there you can you can get
some good experience with react and I'm
not as familiar with angular though so I
can't help you you know quite as much
they're not in terms of what we're good
resources are okay John says when you
have no container for your markup you
can use grid flex will work a bit but
not easily all right you know what John
I kind of wish I had seen that earlier
but all right I'm gonna keep that in
mind though and then maybe you know will
try to use grid two to display those and
at least on desktop we can display them
in in two columns instead of just one
column
soli says which CMS produced this markup
it's an old dotnet framework based CMS
called Ektron so it's e k TR o n so i I
almost never come across it someone who
even has heard of it I never heard of it
until I got this job so it's I think
it's rare
Oh Meyer says grid does require a parent
component holding the children in his
case he has none I believe yeah that's
true we don't have any John says it's
easy enough to wrap the component in a
grid div I yeah you know what maybe the
solution is gonna be that we may have to
add some things with JavaScript off to
see if that's gonna be possible so Lee
said the current content is over 500
page in WordPress but it was brought
over from an older CMS that's correct
and it's actually more than 500 pages
it's I haven't really counted but I mean
potentially like we're looking at over a
thousand so it's it's quite a lot I'm
trying to condense it as much as I can
and clean up the data I think there's
there's a lot that does not need to be
split out into different you know pages
or posts in WordPress and there's some
stuff that we can just completely delete
so we'll see what the count is once I
get it all cleaned up but as of right
now if we're looking at over a thousand
things I don't even have all the data
transferred over yet Maya says I'm
getting noise oh I'm I'm sorry I didn't
see that earlier let me know if it's if
anybody else was getting noise or if
you're still getting any noise let's you
have questions help me please what
JavaScript framework for CSS animation
is the best or vanilla J's is the best
way green sock a lot of people use
something called green sock for for
animation or a JavaScript animation
trying for CSS animation I'm not sure I
mean if you want to mix JavaScript in as
well try out Green suck I'm not sure
about a CS
animation framework the lone wolf says
any suggestions about how many hours I
should dedicate to the free code camp
front-end course per day honestly I
would if you can spend an hour a day at
it I think that's good as long as you
can be consistent I mean like it depends
on what you're doing like right now if
you have another job shoot for an hour a
day if you can if you don't have another
job and you can dedicate more time to it
then you know try to dedicate more time
but if you could do an hour or half hour
every day that'll keep it in your mind
every day and you'll be much more likely
to to retain the information that you
learn flow ves says my Raspberry Pi
arrives in two days any ideas what what
I could do with it okay if anyone has
any ideas about what to do with the
Raspberry Pi put it in the in the chat
please or if you're watching later on
you can put it in the comments yeah you
can do one of those smart mirrors with
the Raspberry Pi right I've always
wanted to do one of those those look
really cool but I guess there's there's
so much stuff I that I've seen people do
that are really cool I guess it kind of
depends on how much work you want to do
how much money you want to put into it
soli says which extension adds that
tooltip for the h2 title I actually have
no idea what extension that is I was
surprised when it showed up that's the
first time I had ever used it let's see
let's see what it is see if we can see
let's check my extensions maybe we might
be able to tell just by the titles of
the extensions ok CSS to react guessing
not
hmm okay it's not really obvious just
from my the names of my extensions what
what does that so I'm not sure I don't
really want to take the time to go
through all of them but I'll leave this
on the screen so at least you can see
some of the extensions I'm using and try
them out so I'm listening to Spotify in
the background and right now a song came
on and it's Ed Sheeran doing a cover of
Britney Spears hit me baby one more time
it's just so weird to hear that
alright then Bhargav says I'm a beginner
I don't know anything but I have a craze
about programming please help me to
learn I yeah I mean just stick around
the streams and ask a lot of questions
if you have any specific questions let
me know I'm happy to help and there's a
lot of other people here that are you
know very helpful lone-wolf ask if
there's any implementation of jQuery
here no in this project we're not using
any jQuery
[Music]
Bhargav says how can I learn this
programming I mean we did a lot of CSS
today so I mean you do basic CSS
tutorials Phoenix AZ start free code
camp yet actually that's a great place
to start go to free code camp org
and you know sign up and just do some of
the exercises that'll get you started
you know you'll start out with some
really basic stuff and work your way up
in difficulty and complexity and that
will give you a really good idea too of
if this is for you if you know if you
really like the word
Vlad asks if there will be training
projects on angular I don't plan on
doing anything with angular for my live
streams but we did have angular video
recently on free code camp so if you
check back you know through last maybe
you scroll back it's somewhere in the
last like 10 videos or so that we
released there was one about angular so
check that out and I haven't watched it
yet but you know that may be a good
place to start
South Vic says which one is good to
learn flask I don't really know anything
about flask so I wouldn't be able to
help you if anybody knows about flask
please let sarthak know here in the in
the live chat or in the comments to the
video let's see
Bhargav says why don't you start your
own company to be honest with you for my
doing your own company involves a lot of
work that's not coding work and I'm just
not interested in that work so I don't
know if if there was if I had a partner
that was interested in all that work
meaning like the work of doing taxes
doing payroll collecting payments from
clients marketing the company if there
are people that were interested in that
and I could just do the code I would be
ok with that but I was freelance I had
to do all that stuff before I just don't
enjoy it I'd rather just spend my time
doing coding and let somebody else worry
about that so that's one of the reasons
why I don't start my own company
how many says shout out from Tunisia
happy to be with you
awesome awesome thank you I'm glad
you're with us too John says I know this
is a nudge to installing style
components but you can
and append all the incoming markup tags
was styled ie conch style left title
equals title your CSS here okay i hmm I
didn't realize we could do that off
maybe we'll have to look into that more
ash Ashwini's says need help and
documentation actually I'm not sure if
you're asking if I need help with
documentation or if you're saying that
you need help and documentation so let
me know which is which
we always need help with everything so
if you'd like to check out the
repository for this project or some of
the other projects that we've been doing
links in the description and submit a
pull request working on some of the
documentation that would be awesome it's
definitely it's not expected or required
of anyone but it's definitely
appreciated scrub scrub is says how did
you setup react on Salesforce I said I
didn't do when we did stuff with
Salesforce we didn't setup react with
Salesforce that would be awesome but I
never did it we just used like plain
CSS and JavaScript Hammami says isn't it
better to use our REM instead of pixels
yeah Myra says yes it's better yeah you
know what that's something that keeps
coming up as well I just use pixels
because in my mind I kind what size in
terms of pixels I need and what will
work I I haven't used
eeehm or REM enough to be able to
visualize that yet so that's why I just
fall back on pixels so I would really
have to make an effort to try to use REM
more when I could get to that point so
you know especially for streams when
I'm trying to talk and do this at the
same time and try to do it quickly
I just default back to pixels so and
that's just I started out with pixels
and that's you know what I use 90% of
the time at least so that's that's just
kind of where my mind is let's see it
scrolled me down to the bottom and I
lost my place let me scroll back okay
John says I guess I'm shocked that those
tags are being accepted as HTML markup
the w3 consortium validator would never
pass it yeah I I don't worry about that
the validator but I mean they're just it
probably just reads it as you know
custom elements which which are okay
how many says if you want Jessie tell us
about some keyboard shortcuts you use
Charlie what do I use I don't know what
I use that's like beyond just the normal
stuff I mean in the terminal obviously
you know you use your up and down arrow
keys to go through pass commands use tab
for autocomplete a lot so both in the
terminal and you know in my my editor
other than that I'm not really it would
probably help if I did learn more more
hotkeys but you know right now I you
know just use some really basic ones I
wish I use more I wish I had a cool ER
answer for that but I just use probably
you know basic ones that most people
know about Raul says hi and I see you
back remember me
wish me luck Sunday is my entrance my
last chance oh okay well good yeah
definitely good luck with that
and let us know if you can let us know
how everything goes you know next next
week okay so Raul Sharma says was going
through YouTube and the title got me
okay cool so the title so I guess a lot
of people you know maybe maybe it was
the title of basic CSS that you know
people responded to Eddie says are you
still in school are you working for a
company yes so I'm working for for a
university so I'm a full-time front-end
developer working for a company solely
says I'm I'm new but since I follow free
code camp I got a notification from
YouTube that there will be a basic CSS
styling live stream never done react
though but I think I will go back and do
it okay cool yeah yeah I didn't really
want this to be like about react I
wanted to try
stick to the CSS as much as possible but
we ended up having to do a little react
stuff at the end but you know hopefully
it was there was enough CSS in there
that it was maybe useful to some people
chat places I subscribe to this channel
since I don't know react well I watched
recorded episodes from Project 1 okay
cool cool how many just activated
notifications on your channel I'm
currently doing the free code camp
algorithms flow that's the same cool
darshan asked where the github link is
for the code we developed today it
should be in the description to this
video so there should be a link to the
github repo says is there a standard
free code camp link or is the same as
Airbnb repo that yesterday you posted
enzyme and Jeff stuff on yeah it should
be the link should be in the description
so it'll be like fu s - mark home slash
Franciscan - reacts that'll be the
that'll be part of the link it'll be a
github link and that'll be the end of it
hard knock muscle says if you started
your own company what would it be I
guess it would be cool to have a company
like based around like a product like
let's say I had a good idea and you know
could just dedicate time to that I mean
I don't know what it would be but you
know some sort of web-based you know
service or something otherwise you know
maybe some sort of agency that we did
work for I just I don't know I don't
know how I really feel about about an
agency I've done some work with agencies
before and I there's good and bad to it
right I mean it's kind of cool that you
get to work on different things but yeah
I don't know that I mean you you're
always having to look for new clients
and so there's not a lot of stability
necessarily yeah so I don't know I'm not
really sure but something along those
lines I guess would be you know what I'd
want to do Alicia are you doing CSS
styling right now no I mean right we're
just kind of doing question-and-answer
stuff right now so if you want to see
the CSS part you can watch the recording
you can go back and watch the beginning
and we did that like the the end here
we're just doing question answer so if
you have any questions please you know
feel free to put them in in the live
chat
Nino says what would you consider
yourself a web designer a web developer
I consider myself a developer that does
design occasionally when when I need to
so we don't really have where I work at
we don't have a dedicated web designer
so I do have to do some of that work but
it's it's I think a small part of what I
do so I've with a lot of help from
Google's material design I've developed
a style guide for university websites
and then I basically follow that style
guide so I don't have to come up with
brand new designs every time I just I I
use you know basic framework that is
that I've developed and then you know
design some elements as needed if
something new comes up
John says it's usually the people here
on Chad who let Jesse know about the
cool keyboard shortcuts yeah that's for
sure you all give me so many really
awesome tips about stuff like that hey I
learned so much from you Oh mmm he says
is it possible to work as developer for
free like for donation like a donation
yeah okay so I'm not I'm not understand
sure how you mean that like you could
donate your services to someone else
that's definitely possible I I do that
for some organizations around here like
some nonprofits or are you saying like
people would donate to you for your work
that's also possible so the at Henry's
Henry's ooh he's at left pad on Twitter
he recently quit his full-time job to
volunteer to maintain the Babel
repository full-time and he right now
he's living off of donations so the last
time I heard I think it was up to like
on his patreon they've donated it's like
three thousand dollars a month for him
to work full-time on on this open source
project on Babel so I think that's
really cool that that would actually be
pretty awesome to do
okay oh and or Sean says VolunteerMatch
dot-org has some coding positions okay
cool I've never been to volunteer my
start over but that might be you know
cool to check out alright wow I've
finally gotten to the bottom of the chat
today was we had a lot in the chat which
is awesome I always loved that a lot of
new people so thank you all for watching
and especially for the new people thank
you so much and thanks for letting me
know how you how you got here on how you
found this and you know I'd love to see
you back at some point and if any of
y'all have any any advice for how the
stream could be better you know what you
liked or disliked about it you know
please let me know I won't get upset if
you have any criticism I really do want
to make the screen better for you all so
you know I welcome any any type of
criticism or advice you have so I
shouldn't be back tomorrow trying to
think about my schedule tomorrow alright
I don't remember what my schedule is
tomorrow definitely have meetings in the
morning so the stream won't be in the
morning it'll more than likely be
sometime in the afternoon Eastern Time
but I'll try to schedule stream as early
as I can I'll post on Twitter I'll post
on Instagram so if you're interested and
you you want to get notifications
definitely subscribe to free code camps
channel turn on notifications if you'd
like you can also follow me on Twitter
and or Instagram and I'll post something
about that too just to let you know
streams gonna happen
yeah and I thank you all so much again
and until tomorrow have a wonderful day